bonsoir et bienvenue ravi de vous
retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce soir
sommes-nous devenus allergique au
travail c'est la thèse que vous
développez Pascal perib bonsoir bonsoir
merci d'être notre grand témoin
génération farniente aux éditions de
l'archipel vous racontez le désamour
entre les Français et le travail qui
selon vous ne date pas d'hier mais qui
s'est retrouvé au cœur de la bataille
des retraites à leur faut-il vraiment
son désole et vos nous le direz tout à
l'heure notre grand débat ce soir
comment atteindre le plein emploi pour y
parvenir le gouvernement veut
conditionner le RSA des contre des
contreparties pardon jusqu'à 15h
d'activités hebdomadaires pour toucher
le revenu de solidarité active alors
est-ce que c'est la solution vers
l'insertion la réponse de nos invités
sur ce plateau dans un instant enfin
nous affranchis ce soir l'économie avec
Fanny guidochet l'international avec le
grand reporter Vincent Huget et puis
Bourbon Express raconté ce soir par Elsa
mondain Gava voilà pour le menu on y va
Pascal Perry
[Musique]
trois lettres trois lettres qui laissent
présager d'un débat où le dans
l'hémicycle et il a commencé RSA pour
revenus de solidarité active c'est le
dernier filet de sécurité offert au plus
démunis le gouvernement qui veut
conditionner son versement à quelques
heures d'activité obligatoire par
semaine c'est la mesure phare du projet
de loi DIPLINE emploi en débat à
l'Assemblée depuis hier le RSA des
droits et donc des devoirs
avec vous Mark ferrachi Rachid bonsoir
merci d'être là vous êtes député
renaissance des Français établis en
Suisse vous êtes économiste du travail
et ancien conseiller social à Matignon
bonsoir Jérôme Guedj merci d'être avec
nous députés socialistes de l'Essonne
membres de la Nupe spécialiste des
questions sociales et vice-président de
la Mecque exactement
co-président vous nous direz à quoi ça
sert dans un tout petit instant côté
entreprise bonsoir Benoît serres merci
d'être avec nous vous présider
l'association des DRH de France et puis
côté salarié Céline vers lequel est
thibautoir merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes secrétaire confédéral à la CGT
Pascal Perry évidemment l'économiste
l'ancien chef d'entreprise que vous êtes
à toute sa part dans ce débat on
commence par planter le décor qu'est-ce
que le RSA qui le perçoit et comment le
gouvernement veut le réformer c'est le
chrono de Blacko pour commencer
bonsoir mon cher Stéphane bonsoir Myriam
bonsoir à toutes et tous alors
s'est mis en tête de réformer le RSA
c'est vraisemblablement parce que la
Cour des comptes lui a soufflé l'idée
dans un rapport qu'elle a publié en
janvier
2022 alors si on peut résumer 200 pages
pour des comptes en une phrase et bien
on dirait que d'un côté la Cour des
comptes trouve que le RSA joue son rôle
pour prémunir de la pauvreté ceux qui en
bénéficient en revanche pour ce qui est
de permettre la réinsertion dans le
monde du travail là c'est beaucoup moins
efficace avec des chiffres qui étaient
dans ce rapport 25% des bénéficiaires
sont inscrits au RSA depuis moins d'un
an sur la période de 1 à 5 ans
d'inscription sur 40% des gens mais le
chiffre qui inquiétait plus l'accord des
comptes c'était bien sûr le fait que
plus d'un tiers des bénéficiaires du RSA
y sont depuis minimum 5 ans et même la
moitié de ses 35% ils sont depuis une
dizaine d'années donc finalement ça fait
plus tellement en tremplin vers ça fait
plutôt trap un peu à pauvreté quand on
voit ces chiffres là donc le résultat
c'est que deux mois plus tard le
candidat Macron s'est emparé de ce
rapport pour le transformer en promesse
électorale en disant et bien désormais
pour bénéficier du RSA il faudra un
minimum de 15 heures d'activités par
semaine alors vous allez débattre du
fond et d'un point de vue politique il
faut reconnaître que c'était plutôt
bienvenu une bonne idée en tout cas
puisque l'idée est très populaire vous
allez voir 80% des Français étaient
favorables à la proposition à la
promesse du candidat et même à gauche
vous voyez il y a la majorité que ça
soit chez les insoumis les socialistes
ou les écologistes qui trouvent que
après tout oui une contrepartie dans ce
domaine ça serait pas non plus injuste
donc le résultat c'est qu'au début du
stop est assez confiant quand il va à
l'Assemblée il assume clairement la
position du gouvernement en matière de
lutte contre la pauvreté en écoute
il faut en finir je crois avec le totem
de l'aide contre la pauvreté qui passe
que sans contrepartie serait par essence
meilleur que toutes les autres et ce
même si en réalité elle enferme il large
partie de ceux qui en bénéficient dans
la misère alors évidemment à gauche on
pense exactement le contraire avec un
argument que moi je suis assez percutant
je parle sous le contrôle des députés
Guedj et ferrachi qui sont spécialistes
des charges patronales en 2023 les
prévisions disent que les entreprises
devraient bénéficier de 88 milliards
d'allègement de charge pas trop mal mais
sans de contrepartie particulière que ce
soit attendue en revanche pourquoi
est-ce qu'on demanderait aux gens qui
touchent le RSA d'avoir des
contreparties ça coûte 15 milliards le
RSA on écoute Arthur de la porte PS
nous on a déposé d'ailleurs une note à
la Fondation Jean Jaurès sont devenant
défend l'idée d'un revenu inconditionnel
ouvert au moins de 25 ans et revalorisé
un minimum social un revenu d'existence
bref on a compris que c'est pas du côté
de la news que le gouvernement va
trouver les voies qui manquent comme
bien souvent c'est plutôt du côté de LR
que ce porte-clé regarde alors la droite
sénatoriale elle avait fixée un minimum
de 15 heures obligatoires d'activités
pour bénéficier de RSA il semblerait que
les députés LR1 soient prêts à assouplir
un petit peu ce critère on écoute
Philippeville
bien sûr parfois nous le savons tous les
circonstances personnelles de
l'intéressé feront que ça ne sera pas
possible il ne pourra pas faire les 15
heures et bien dans ces cas-là il fera
moins soit mais il ne doit jamais faire
zéro bref un petit peu de suspense
comment mais sur le vote LR on verra
bien en tout cas la question est posée
le RSA c'est 607 euros pardon pour une
personne alors c'est un droit mais
est-ce qu'on doit le supprimer si en
échange on n'a pas quitté ce devoir bah
le débat est ouvert merci beaucoup le
décor est planté merci Stéphane vous le
disiez 607 euros 75 pour une personne
seule on va tout de suite regarder ce
tableau un couple avec enfants
1276 euros 29 et un petit peu moins pour
une mère célibataire qui aurait deux
enfants Marc ferratti il y a deux
millions d'allocataires au RSA dans
notre pays on a compris que c'est des
situations très très difficiles on parle
des mères isolés on parle aussi de
situations parfois où il y a une
difficulté de santé une difficulté de
dégringolade social et toutes les études
de terrain en témoignent en quoi ce
dispositif va permettre à ces personnes
de remettre un pied dans le monde
professionnel et est-ce que vous avez
des garanties que ça marche moi je veux
partir de ce chiffre de 607 euros parce
que
c'est le point de départ qui explique la
philosophie du projet de loi avec 607
euros on vit par on survit et donc les
gens qui sont en situation de bénéficier
du RSA on doit tout faire pour les
accompagner vers une vie meilleure une
vie professionnelle meilleure vers un
revenu plus élevé vers une intégration
sociale qui peut passer par le travail
et de ce point de vue les chiffres de la
Cour des comptes l'ont suggéré mais il y
a beaucoup beaucoup d'autres éléments
qui le montrent et bien on a un échec
collectif depuis 1988 depuis qui a été
créé le RMI depuis 2008 depuis qui a été
créé le RSA c'est l'accompagnement des
personnes vers l'emploi et vers une
intégration sociale et professionnelle
donc vous me posez la question de savoir
est-ce que ça va marcher on a bon espoir
que ça marche pourquoi parce que d'abord
une grande partie des bénéficiaires du
RSA je pense la grande majorité d'entre
eux souhaite s'insérer soit être
s'insérer ne trouve pas face à eux un
service un accompagnement des solutions
pour aller vers l'emploi qui soit
suffisamment adapté à leurs problèmes et
qui soit suffisamment efficace certains
ont des problèmes de formation il faut
les mettre à niveau certains ont des
problèmes de frein périphériques il faut
d'abord résoudre le sujet de la garde
d'enfant le sujet du surendettement le
sujet de la santé avant de s'engager
dans un parcours vers l'emploi et donc
ça appelle des réponses personnalisées
ce qu'on veut faire avec ce projet de
loi c'est d'abord faire en sorte que les
décisions soient prises au plus près du
terrain avec une meilleure coordination
un meilleur dialogue entre les acteurs
il faut savoir que les collectivités
territoriales Pôle emploi qui demain
s'appellera je l'espère France travail
l'émission locale tous ces acteurs ont
parfois du mal à se parler sur le
terrain et si on veut traiter les
problèmes des gens de manière efficace
il faut se dialogue donc avec un contrat
un contrat d'engagement en donnant
donnant obligatoire cette fois pour les
bénéficiaires
ça existe déjà ça s'appelle le contrat
d'engagement réciproque alors en réalité
le principe est qu'on devrait le signer
la pratique est que une minorité de
bénéficiaires du RSA aussi aujourd'hui
et ça ça va changer on souhaite que ça
change parce que la logique de droit et
devoirs qui sous-tend ce projet de loi
c'est une logique dans laquelle le
service public de l'emploi doit des
solutions aux personnes doit un
accompagnement de qualité doit un
conseiller et un contact humain pour
aller vers l'emploi et dans laquelle la
personne doit aussi 15 à 20h d'activités
et j'en termine pour ne pas être trop
long pour dire que ce débat autour des
15 20 heures c'est un débat que nous
avons eu pendant la campagne
présidentielle nous l'avons dit à
l'époque Elizabeth borne qui était
ministre du Travail le disait je le
disais moi-même quand je discutais du
programme on sait très bien que
certaines personnes ne sont pas capables
d'assumer 15 à 20h d'activités parce
qu'elles ont des problèmes trop lourds à
gérer des problèmes psychologiques des
problèmes de santé des problèmes
familiaux on veut que le système puisse
tenir compte de ces situations
particulières
il y aura des accessoires pour certains
cas particuliers et peut-être peut-être
erreur mais ça
aux personnes qui sont sur le terrain
dans des idées ça n'est de mon point de
vue en tout cas je souhaite qu'on
préserve la philosophie de ce projet de
loi qui est de laisser la décision à
ceux qui sont les plus proches du
terrain c'est-à-dire les conseillers
Jérôme Gadi 18 départements où la mesure
a été expérimentée
apparemment les allocataires sont mieux
suivis parce qu'il y a des conseillers
plus nombreux à leur écoute c'est ce
qu'on peut regarder dans certains
reportages à Épinal par exemple je ne
sais pas s'il y a un retour d'expérience
globale de ces 18 départements mais
apparemment d'après ce que j'ai pu lire
en préparant ce débat c'est plutôt c'est
plutôt positif et vous vous dites
attention chasse aux pauvres vraiment
vous voyez ça dans ce dispositif oui
alors moi je vais m'exprimer moins en
parlementaire qui légifère je viens de
quitter l'hémicycle parce qu'il y a une
information qui a pas été précisée c'est
que le RSA comme le RMI hier est versé
par les départements c'est à dire que
j'ai pendant longtemps été conseillé
général puis conseiller départemental
j'étais président d'un département j'ai
siégé dans les commissions locales
d'insertion on a mis en place un plan
départemental d'insertion etc et je
pense qu'il faut tordre le coup à une
idée mais Marc Ferracci avec son
honnêteté intellectuelle la rappeler
c'est que on entretient une confusion
les deux millions des allocataires du
RSA aujourd'hui tout le monde sait que
tous n'ont pas vocation à l'insertion
professionnelle tout le monde le sait à
quelle proportion et dans des
proportions aujourd'hui il y a 40% des
des c'est extrêmement variables 30 40%
quand j'entends Olivier du socle qui
disait lui-même la semaine dernière en
commission des affaires sociales c'est
vrai qu'il y a une partie non
négligeable de ces allocataires pour
lequel ce n'est pas l'objectif de
l'insertion professionnelle de l'emploi
parce que des problèmes de santé mentale
des problèmes de mobilité de logements
des gens très éloignés de l'emploi des
gens pas très éloignés de la retraite
pour lesquelles de toute façon
malheureusement l'accès au marché du
travail est compliqué donc là on est
dans une sorte de stigmatisation en
disant vous avez un minima social qui en
plus est en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
et en contrepartie il faut absolument
que vous fassiez ce travail pardon dès
le droit de le dire gratuit parce que la
réalité ça veut dire qu'on la
contrepartie de ces pour les 607 euros
15 heures ça veut dire
parfois à remplir un CV c'est pas
forcément une activité un travail mais
sauf que vous voyez l'ambiguïté ça va
m'en entretenu en disant en gros c'est
fainéant de pauvre voilà ces assistés il
faut qu'ils aillent il faut qu'ils
aillent au boulot je réponds à votre
question parce que ça pour moi c'est un
problème de parlementaire pour le coup
c'est qu'on légifère sur un changement
significatif alors qu'il y a une
expérimentation et contrairement il y a
des témoignages des reportages mais il
n'y a pas de document consolidés
d'évaluation de ces expérimentations
c'est quand même assez fantastique on
fait une loi il n'y a pas de document
consolidés pire dans l'étude d'impact et
ça c'est l'actualité du jour parce que
j'en parlais tout à l'heure dans les
disciples nous ça fait des semaines
qu'on demande est-ce que la sanction
puisque Stéphane Blacko qui leur a
appelé tout à l'heure si on respecte pas
le contrat d'engagement on va avoir une
sanction suspension du RSA problème
c'est que ça fait des années que ça
existe il y a des il y a des sanctions
suppression il y a une sanction
suspension qui manifestement est plus
souple dans le texte aujourd'hui au
moment où je vous parle quand on
demandait au ministre Olivier du soft
quel est l'impact des sanctions qui
existent depuis des années aussi ingrat
que ça puisse paraître et bah il a dit
j'ai pas de résultats je suis incapable
de vous dire
que
j'ai simplicité vendredi avec mes
responsabilités de co-présidents de la
mission d'évaluation le directeur
général de la CNAV il m'a transmis hier
à 23h38 des chiffres qui montrent que
les sanctions de se traduisent pas par
un retour à l'emploi du retour
d'expérience sur du vent comme
d'ailleurs les études d'impact
normalement elles sont légales il faut
les avoir et après on fait circuler
évidemment on va vous on va vous donner
sur sur l'impact d'abord sur le retour
d'expérience les expérimentations ça a
été dit dès le départ non pas vocation a
décidé si on va mettre en oeuvre le
dispositif ou pas elles sont destinées à
collecter les bonnes pratiques avoir ce
qui marche à voir ce qui ne marche pas
et à inspirer ensuite la mise en oeuvre
sur l'ensemble du territoire du
dispositif c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne et c'est comme ça que je
l'espère on ira plus vite vers de
l'efficacité maintenant sur les
sanctions vous savez
moi je suis universitaire de profession
j'aime bien qu'on documente les choses
et donc je suis toujours très attentif
d'ailleurs on l'a été ensemble sur un
autre rapport à la question de l'impact
des mesures des articles scientifiques
qui ont évalué l'effet des sanctions sur
le retour à l'emploi il y en a des
dizaines il y en a des dizaines je vous
invite par exemple à lire un article de
synthèse qui a été écrit dans la Revue
Française d'Économie par trois
chercheurs ces livresco François
fontaine Franck malherbey qui fait une
synthèse de ces choses là et qui
explique avec des évaluations causales
contrefactuelles et pas simplement avec
les statistiques descriptives que vous
avez demandé aux autorités qui ne disent
pas grand chose en réalité sur les faits
vous observez que quelqu'un retourne à
l'emploi après une sanction ça n'est pas
forcément l'effet de la sanction parce
que la personne qui a été sanctionnée a
peut-être des caractéristiques
différentes de celles des personnes qui
ne l'ont pas été et donc il faut des
travaux académiques qui permettent de
contrôler ces problèmes qu'on appelle
des biais c'est assez travaux là que moi
je me réfère quand je dis que les
sanctions ça marche il y en a beaucoup
comme ça je me tourne vers le
l'entreprise Benoît sert on a dit tout à
l'heure que et c'était bien d'ailleurs
que ce soit partagé tous les
allocataires ne sont pas forcément en
capacité de retrouver le chemin de la
vie professionnelle mais il faut encore
que les entreprises pour ceux qui
veulent ceux qui le peuvent les
embauches dans quel secteur vous voyez
ça est-ce que vous pensez que les
entreprises vont jouer le jeu alors
d'abord elle joue toutes ces entreprises
ont énormément développé leur politique
d'insertion depuis assez longtemps pas
forcément à l'égard des bénéficiaires du
RSA mais sur d'autres typologies de
population éloignées de l'emploi et ça
marche plutôt d'ailleurs il faut
reconnaître que même si c'est par
exemple le travail qui est lycée
professionnel travail sur l'alternance
de bas niveau a permis quand même de
donc ça c'est des outils d'insertion
maintenant ce que j'ai vu et ce que j'ai
entendu après la décision passée après
une politique vu l'entreprise que je
trouve est pharaon c'est les chiffres
que Stéphane blasgowski a rappelé vous
pensez qu'il y a 35% des gens qui sont
au RSA depuis des années j'imagine que
dans ces 35% là ils sont pas tous avec
des problèmes mentaux c'est bon je pense
qu'on un vrai sujet c'est pour ça qu'on
met nous un peu d'espoir dans France
travail et les réformes des services
publics de l'emploi parce qu'on le vit
tous les jours quand vous êtes dans une
entreprise dont on dit qu'il y a 2
millions de personnes vous imaginez bien
qu'un certain qui rêvent de bosser
j'imagine et que nous on a des problèmes
de recrutement tous les matins même sur
des postes à faible niveau de
qualification donc c'est même pas le
sujet dit qu'il y a quelque chose qui
marche pas et c'est vrai que quand on
est dans les territoires vous l'avez
très bien dit la coordination entre Pôle
emploi la paix pour les cadres les
commissions c'est les entreprises qui
essaient de s'y retrouver résultat des
courses on passe pas par là or le
problème
on se débrouille par système de réseau
on se débrouille par les cabinets on se
débrouille par des cabinets d'intérim
c'est que l'intérim c'est la première
emploi ça c'est un vrai sujet je dis pas
que le sujet qui est traité ne l'est pas
je dis que ce sujet là c'est un sujet à
traiter d'urgence parce que du coup ces
gens-là sont éloignés de l'emploi ils
sont en plus éloignés des réseaux et des
systèmes donc on a encore plus de mal et
je crains que et je j'accuse personne ne
Pôle emploi mais il y a un vrai sujet je
pense qu'il y a un point important c'est
effectivement il y a toute une une
partie qui n'est plus accessible à
l'emploi pour des raisons personnelles
vous l'avez rappelé de santé de famille
se couler cela il relève de la
solidarisation nationale et d'autres qui
doivent être traités en priorité et
surtout avoir un critère ou non le fait
en entreprise comment fait-on pour
éviter quelqu'un soit pendant 2 ans 3
ans totalement décroché la vie réelle
parce que le raccroché l'entreprise de
sait pas le faire et aujourd'hui les
systèmes de plusieurs points ont
beaucoup de mal à le faire alors côté
entreprise on attend ce projet de loi
avec impatience côté syndicat est-ce que
ça va dans le bon sens cette idée d'un
donnant donnant sachant qu'il y a aussi
un système de sanction si vous ne jouez
pas le jeu du contrat d'engagement et
bien on peut vous suspendre au bout de
combien de temps de trois mois c'est ça
on peut suspendre dès lors que les
obligations ne sont pas remplies
alors après quels sont les conséquences
ce qui est en algorithme
pour comprendre comment elles peuvent
être effectives pour la personne
concernée à la CGT comment on regarde le
dispositif
de manière très négative forcément parce
que là on mélange tout en fait parce
qu'on a l'impression que le RSA c'est un
revenu par que ce n'est pas un revenu on
est bien d'accord c'est une aide sociale
vous l'avez dit et c'est une indemnité
donc non normalement c'est simplement
pour en effet éviter que des personnes
vivent avec rien parce qu'au final de
leur demander quelque chose avec rien
déjà enfin moi je sais pas si vous
pouvez vous en rendre compte mais vivre
avec 600 euros c'est très très compliqué
ça veut dire que vous êtes en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté vous l'avez vu aussi
les chiffres le disent c'est 40%
aujourd'hui des personnes qui
bénéficient du RSA qui sont aussi à Pôle
emploi en recherche d'emploi les 60%
restantes c'est des personnes qui ne
sont pour l'instant pas en tout cas en
capacité justement de travailler ça il
faut le prendre en compte et quand vous
parlez de la Cour des comptes qui a dit
en effet que il y avait pas de retour
d'emploi pour les bénéficiaires du RSA
après il faudrait aussi lire la suite du
rapport il donne des indications ils
disent notamment
c'est le fait qu'il n'y ait pas
suffisamment d'accompagnement pour le
retour à l'emploi qui dit accompagnement
c'est pas d'obliger les gens à
travailler sur des secteurs pour
lesquels ne serait même pas qualifiés
c'est c'est justement les aider à
pouvoir retourner vers l'emploi pour ce
pour qui ça serait possible parce que en
effet il y a des personnes en situation
de handicap il y a des personnes et
beaucoup des personnes qui sont âgées et
qui ne peuvent plus travailler non plus
des personnes qui ont besoin pour se
réinsérer alors justement on arrive à la
question de l'accompagnement
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
accompagnement précisément si
aujourd'hui on dit que le RSA c'est en
contrepartie d'un travail et bien ce
n'est plus une aide sociale ce n'est
plus une indemnité dans ces cas-là il
faut qu'il y ait un vrai revenu un
revenu à une personne qui cotise aussi
parce qu'il n'y a pas de cotisations et
je dirais que par contre c'est une très
bonne opération pour le patronat parce
que là franchement c'est du travail
gratos pour le patron alors on voit bien
les arguments vous allez répondre mais
j'aimerais bien vous entendre parce que
l'accompagnement normalement et ça va
coûter cher
on va y venir c'est quand même des
chiffres dans les départements des
travailleurs sociaux qui va falloir
recruter en plus dans l'émission locale
pour être au plus près à faire des
formules ce qui coûte le plus cher c'est
le nom d'emploi finalement c'est les 70
milliards d'euros chaque année
d'assistance sociale et je fais écho à
ce qu'indique madame vergeletti la
différence entre l'assurance et
l'assistance c'est dans l'assurance la
retraite par exemple ou l'assurance
maladie on produit ses droits ceux qui
n'ont plus de travail ne produisent plus
de droit et
ayant épuisé leur droit au chômage
vivent de l'assistance et vous voyez en
quoi c'est dangereux aujourd'hui vous
avez vu la gentillesse de rappeler tout
à l'heure que j'ai été chef d'entreprise
j'ai dirigé des entreprises
industrielles et m'est arrivé d'employer
ou de chercher employer des gens qui
étaient hors de l'emploi pendant très
longtemps c'est très compliqué c'est un
problème extrêmement complexe c'est pas
un problème technique c'est d'abord un
problème humain c'est-à-dire qu'il
s'agit de ressocialiser une population
qui est sortie de la société
lui apprendre à être à l'heure
respecter les trois vides quand on fait
les trois huit mais les principaux
problèmes s'agissant du RSA c'est que en
effet on constate que après quelques
années de RSA une population importante
en France ne retourne pas vers l'emploi
et donc il y a une espèce d'assignation
permanente à au RSA qui est évidemment
très stigmatisant ce qui est
stigmatisant c'est pas de demander une
contrepartie c'est de vivre au RSA en
réalité donc il faut examiner point par
point les freins à l'emploi les freins à
l'emploi c'est le logement c'est la
question des transports et c'est surtout
surtout la question de la formation pour
travailler dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
il faut savoir faire quelque chose et il
faut la prendre écouter en dépense 30
milliards d'euros chaque année en
matière de formation est-ce qu'on n'est
pas capable aujourd'hui d'orienter une
partie de cet argent des formations
juste je termine des formations qui
seraient des formations qualifiantes en
oubliant pas que là aussi expérience de
chef d'entreprise l'échelon pertinent
c'est la proximité et l'outil essentiel
c'est la
alors justement donnez-nous au fond le
modèle parfait si on est à quelle
échelle à quel micro échelle qui
accompagne comment cette personne ne
serait-ce que l'accompagnateur est formé
combien sont recrutés qu'est-ce qui se
dit qu'est-ce qui se fait très très
concrètement de proximité il y a
plusieurs questions d'abord la question
de l'échelle de la maille territoriale
pour moi la maille territoriale doit
être la plus fine possible c'est le
bassin d'emploi ça dépend ensuite de la
structure du territoire ça peut être la
métropole ça peut être une
intercommunalité mais c'est une maille
dans laquelle les besoins qui sont
exprimés par les entreprises peuvent
rencontrer et bien les personnes qui
sont en recherche d'emploi et la
philosophie de ce projet de loi c'est
pas la philosophie d'ailleurs c'est ce
que prévoit ce projet de loi c'est que à
cette maille très fine on partage des
informations qu'on fasse un diagnostic
qui soit efficace et harmonisé sur ce
que sont les freins vous avez dit il y a
des problèmes de formation mais tout le
monde n'a pas forcément des problèmes de
formation parfois la formation à
laquelle les gens ont besoin d'accéder
c'est une formation de remise à niveau
parce sont ils ont passé deux ans ou
trois ans parfois c'est une formation
longue et qualifiante parfois en réalité
ils sont directement employables auprès
des entreprises
combien de personnes pour faire ce
travail d'accompagnement je serai très
heureux d'avoir la réponse parce que ça
fait partie des choses sur lesquelles on
a zéro information vous avez justement
dit que il y a besoin de renforcer ce
service public de l'emploi et de
l'insertion en France actuellement le
ratio personnel à Pôle emploi et
personne accompagnées il est deux fois
inférieur à ce qu'il y a en
Grande-Bretagne et en Allemagne on fait
souvent de la comparaison avec nos
voisins européens donc et à aucun moment
les ministres n'ont plus nous dire voilà
le nombre de personnels qu'on va
recruter dans les départements à Pôle
emploi que vous rebaptisez France
travail mais vous ripolinez le nom mais
il y a pas un moyen supplémentaire qui
est confié je ne vais pas répondre à la
place des ministres
il y a effectivement 40% seulement des
bénéficiaires du RSA qui sont
aujourd'hui inscrits à Pôle emploi et
60% qui restent ne sont pas des gens qui
sont in employables qui sont loin de
l'emploi ce sont des gens qui sont
accompagnés par les départementaux et
par les travailleurs sociaux et qui
parfois dans certains départements
bénéficient d'un accompagnement en
grande qualité moi j'ai été visité les
structures conjointe du département et
de Pôle emploi dans le Nord et bien je
peux vous assurer que ça fonctionne très
bien il y a beaucoup d'hétérogénéité sur
le territoire ce qu'on veut faire c'est
que demain non pas 40 mais 100% des
bénéficiaires du RSA soit inscrits à
Pôle emploi et pour répondre pour tenter
de répondre à Jérôme Guedj l'ambition
qu'on se donne c'est que le taux
d'accompagnement ou le nombre de
conseillers qui traite aujourd'hui des
demandeurs d'emploi et bien s'améliore
s'améliore alors même que la montée en
charge
en revanche il y a des repères et vous
savez que la montée en charge va se
faire de manière progressive vous savez
qu'il y a un repère qui est quand même
donné par le rapport de préfiguration
qui a été rédigé par Thibault Guy lui
qui établit des fourchettes mais des
hauts commissaire à l'emploi compétences
et qui donne une idée de ce que sera en
régime de croisière c'est à dire lorsque
l'on aura atteint c'est 100%
d'inscription les besoins donc moi je
vais pas répondre sur ce que sont à
travers des tableaux Excel les besoins
région parisienne budgétaire dans le
projet de loi de finances on aura les
non mais déjà il y aura des moyens
pas les réponses ils manifester devant
l'Assemblée tout à l'heure
ça va être un projet ça va être oui un
projet de loi qui remet en vigueur donc
une politique d'austérité si si le
projet de loi des finances ça sera moins
de budget notamment pour tous les
secteurs du social donc c'est bien ces
professionnels du social qui devraient
être beaucoup plus en nombre justement
pour accompagner ces personnes là vous
l'avez dit en plus ça va être
contradictoire vous l'avez dit certaines
personnes qui sont très bien accompagnés
ils sont pas en recherche d'un emploi
parce que elles ont besoin d'un
accompagnement ces personnes là si vous
les obligez demain à travailler sinon
elles perdront le bénéfice elles ne
seront plus accompagnées elles seront
obligées de travailler très difficiles
parce qu'on voit bien on voit bien
l'objectif moi je pense que cette
philosophie en tout cas de de cette
réforme elle est très nausée à bonne
parce que ça veut dire d'une c'est ce
que ça allait s'entendre que les
personnes qui seraient au RSA c'est des
personnes finalement qui ne veulent pas
travailler et on va les mettre au
travail on va les obliger parce que ça
suffit de donner de l'argent à des gens
qui veulent pas alors que c'est des
personnes qui sont en extrême propres
le milieu du travail d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça qu'ils ont une situation ne
peuvent plus travailler personne
personne dans la majorité présidentielle
personne au gouvernement ne considère je
reprends le terme qui a été utilisé tout
à l'heure par Jérôme Guedj que je trouve
assez blessant considère les gens qui
sont au RSA comme des fainéants personne
personne
moi j'ai lu l'employable hormis ceux qui
ont des problèmes trop lourds
estimez-vous vous citiez tout à l'heure
Thibault guili le commissaire à l'emploi
il estime le coût de cette mesure à
l'échelle nationale entre deux trois à
deux sept milliards d'euros sauf que
nous avons le coup que nous on a fait un
chiffrage et que si on veut vraiment
atteindre les objectifs d'identifier on
est plus proche de 10 milliards d'euros
vraiment c'est pour avoir un service
public d'accompagnement on a fait je
vous invite à lire une étude qui a été
publiée notamment par mon ami Arthur de
la porte à la Fondation Jean Jaurès et
on est plus proche en montée en régime
de ce chiffre là deuxième chose
d'ailleurs j'en profite puisque vous
dites on atteindra des taux améliorés
dans trois quatre cinq ans est-ce qu'au
moins dans l'intervalle on n'applique
pas les sanctions parce que pour le coup
ils risquent de pas y avoir
d'accompagnement à hauteur suffisant et
par contre des sanctions si on sur le
coup
et je termine sur un point parce que
c'est peut-être ça le plus important le
vrai problème du RSA vous savez c'est
quoi le vrai problème du RSA aujourd'hui
c'est le nom recours il y a 30% des
Français qui auraient droit au RSA et
pour les raisons extrêmement compliquées
au fait de pouvoir pas j'attends de voir
la
solidarités
par contre je vois et toute la semaine
dernière on était en commission avec les
amendements que c'est des procédures qui
vont être toutes dématérialisées
dématérialiser c'est à dire qu'il faut
passer par une connexion Internet pour
pouvoir
remplir les demandes alors qu'on est
face à des publics qui pour partie soit
ils habitent dans des zones blanches 6
millions de Français soit ils sont comme
les 14 millions de Français touchés
de personnes qui devraient toucher le
RSA non mais c'est la Cour des comptes
aussi
un mot d'explication sur les sanctions
et je vous donne la parole Benoît faire
juste après sur les sanctions qu'est-ce
qui existe qu'est-ce qui va changer
alors qu'est-ce qui existe aujourd'hui
quand vous ne respectez pas vos
engagements et que vous avez signé ce
fameux contrat d'engagement réciproque
dont on parlait tout à l'heure en tant
que bénéficiaire du RSA vous pouvez voir
votre allocation supprimer ça veut dire
que même si vous revenez dans une
logique de parcours et vous respectez
ensuite vos engagements vous ne
récupérez pas le RSA ce que c'est très
dur c'est extrêmement dur parce que déjà
607 euros c'est pas beaucoup mais si en
plus on voit la supprime de manière
définitive c'est extrêmement violent et
moi j'a ce terme-là ce que l'on
introduit dans ce texte c'est une autre
sanction plus modérée plus graduelle
qu'on appelle la sanction suspension qui
consiste comme son nom l'indication
suspendre la location mais à permettre
aux personnes qui ensuite après quelques
semaines ou quelques mois et bien
satisfont de nouveau à leurs obligations
de récupérer une partie du RSA et donc
ça c'est un élément qui doit permettre
d'être plus incitatif et de remobiliser
les personnes de les inciter et bien à
rentrer dans les 15 20 heures
on manque à gagner de RSA ce que fait ce
texte en matière de sanction
actuellement c'est quelle proportion de
sanctions ce qu'on fait ce qu'on fait
existe depuis 10 ans les sanctions
de sanctions
sont extrêmement durs pour les raisons
que je viens d'indiquer et je comprends
très bien les travailleurs sociaux
en suspens on l'a bien compris le débat
il commence dans l'hémicycle on va de
suivre évidemment sur LCP et dès qu'on
aura des réponses et bien on essaiera de
les de les expliquer il nous reste peu
de temps et je voulais absolument qu'on
dise un mot parce que vous allez voir
c'est possible de mettre d'accord de
députés qu'a priori tout au pauses
justement on s'interrogeait sur
l'objectif du gouvernement avec cette
mesure c'est c'est le plein emploi
atteindre donc les 5 % de chômage
aujourd'hui on est un peu plus de 7
d'ici 2027 et pour cela il faut prendre
des mesures efficaces et à vous lire
Messieurs les Députés ça n'est pas
toujours le cas puisque votre rapport
montre que les baisses de charge pour
les hauts salaires n'ont pas permis
d'embaucher explication avec Baptiste
garguichartier et je vous donnerai mais
vraiment une poignée de secondes après
pour expliquer tout ça regardez
première question qui est concernée les
entreprises qui rémunèrent les salariés
entre 2,5 et 3,5 SMIC car plus le
salaire est élevé moins l'exonération
semble efficace
autrement dit alléger le coup du travail
sur les plus hauts salaires ne permet
pas de soutenir efficacement l'emploi ni
la compétitivité des entreprises alors
quel serait l'objectif d'une telle
mesure
à l'heure où l'exécutif se dit en quête
d'économie budgétaire la suppression de
cette exonération rapporterait près
d'un,5 milliards d'euros à l'État selon
le dernier rapport une mesure mise en
place sous le quinquennat de François
Hollande pour soutenir la compétitivité
et l'emploi un échec dixit ses deux
parlementaires qui plait pour sa
suppression malgré la vie contraire de
la majorité nous sommes aujourd'hui l'un
des pays champion des prélèvements
obligatoires après tous les efforts
qu'Emmanuel Macron a consenti pour
réduire la voilure nous devons
poursuivre cette politique de baisse de
la fiscalité de baisse des prélèvements
obligatoires mais si les exonérations
sont supprimés quelles seraient les
compensations la suppression du
dispositif et l'objet est une ligne de
crête chaque élu joue sa propre
partition Marc Ferracci propose une
baisse des prélèvements sur les
entreprises en renforçant les
exonérations sur les bas salaires
mesurent décrié par Jérôme Guedj plus
enclin à conditionner les allègements à
des contreparties sociales
environnemental de la part des
entreprises pour leur nul ne sait encore
si cette offensive parlementaire sera
prise en compte par la majorité les
débats ne sont pas envoyés au calendrier
ils auront bien lieu dès le mois
prochain
d'accord
aujourd'hui que ces dispositifs de
baisse de charge patronales n'a pas créé
un seul emploi non il y a un faisceau
d'indices très probant très convergent
avec beaucoup d’études qui disent la
même chose à savoir que à ces niveaux de
salaire alléger le coup du travail et
beaucoup moins efficace et quasiment
inefficace en matière de création
d'emplois que lorsque vous baissez le
coût du travail autour du SMIC les
allègements autour du SMIC il faut les
préserver en en est d'accord je crois
avec avec Jérôme Guedj et effectivement
si on devait supprimer ce milliard et
demi d'exonération sur les eaux salaires
et bien moi je suis partisan non pas de
l'utiliser à d'autres fins en termes de
dépenses mais de baisser de manière plus
efficace la fiscalité ou les charges sur
les entreprises vous avez des charges
sociales sur les bas salaires mais moi
je ferai tout à fait ouvert à ce que on
aille plus vite et plus loin sur la
baisse des impôts de production en
utilisant ce milliards
y compris dans la majorité sont un petit
peu sceptiques mais moi je veux poser la
question de l'efficacité de la dépense
publique parce que aller vers le plein
emploi c'est s'assurer que chaque euro
dépensé pour l'emploi est efficace
rapidement rapidement d'abord Bonne
Nouvelle on était capable d'être
d'accord au moins sur cette proposition
c'est pour ça qu'on voulait sur le
milieu mais derrière ça en fait c'est
une question on a beaucoup entendu
parler de pognon dingue il y a 80
milliards d'euros d'exonération de
cotisations sociales ça a doublé dans
les 10 dernières années il y a pas une
dépense dans le budget de l'État qui a
doublé dans les 10 dernières années or
on les évalue très peu nous on a fait un
sort à une partie d'entre elles mais moi
je souhaite qu'on se pose la question
pas de la totalité il y en a certaines
qui sont efficaces notamment sur les
basses salaires mais il y a problème
probablement et les économistes qu'on
est auditionnés 20 25 milliards sur ces
80 milliards d'euros dont on ne sait pas
c'est réellement
et il y a 10 ans j'avais des doutes sur
le cice et sur son impact notamment sur
la création de l'emploi et même sur la
compétitivité parce que toutes les
entreprises sont pas soumises à la
concurrence internationale donc la bonne
nouvelle c'est que 1 on a mis un pied
dans la porte avec Marc ferrachi pour
dire quel espoir d'aboutir franchement
on va voir moi je vais déposer un
amendement Marc il va aussi déposer un
amendement et on va essayer de prendre
par la tête par l'intelligence nos
collègues en leur disant au moment où la
ressource publique est rare dans le
budget dans le budget de la Sécurité
sociale moi je pense que ça peut être
alloué à d'autres priorités vous savez
quoi je fais un lien avec
l'oreillette
on fait des contreparties vous savez un
chef d'entreprise il remplit une fois
par an un dossier de deux pages pour
avoir les exonérations alors qu'un
allocataire du RSA c'est quatre fois par
an où il doit justifier de ses revenus
et c'est un dossier de 10 pages donc un
moment si on pouvait traiter avec la
même exigence les chefs d'entreprise je
pense que ce serait une preuve d'égalité
à la suppression de toutes les
exonérations des cotisations sociales
pourquoi parce que exonération de
cotisations sociales c'est cadeau pour
le patronat au détriment des salariés
puisque après au salarié qu'est-ce qu'on
dit réforme des retraites les caisses de
sécurité sociale sont bien compris vous
allez devoir traiter Benoît serres vous
disiez tout à l'heure c'est vrai ça crée
pas d'emploi parce qu'effectivement je
partage tout à fait le constat en
revanche la réallocation peut-être un
peu de production ça c'est sûr si on
pouvait aller plus vite ce serait pas
mal mais surtout pour tous les salaires
autour du SMIC parce que là vous avez un
phénomène de surcoût des charges
patronales pour les PME qui fait qu'il
n'augmentent pas les gens c'est le
trababase je pense qu'il y a un vrai
travail à faire pour redescendre autour
des 1,6 Mik mais effectivement je
comprends après c'est pas une affaire de
cadeau ou pas ou patrona c'est pas la
question je pense qu'effectivement ce
type d'aide ne motive pas ou une
influence pas notre capitaine recruter
ce type de profil en revanche l'écart
brut net et le fait qu'il y a un moment
un effet de seuil sur le SPIC
effectivement joue défavorable ment sur
les augmentations
on voulait absolument en parler de ce
rapport parce qu'une fois n'est pas
coutume deux députés qu'a priori la
famille politique oppose sont d'accord
on verra son avenir même les DRH sont
d'accord et même la CGT un certain temps
sur cette mesure voilà l'avenir
rendez-vous au projet de loi de finance
vous restez avec moi merci à vous d'être
venu débattre sur LCP pour votre
expertise sur le fond des sujets Pascal
Perry vous restez avec moi dans une
dizaine de minutes les parties pris de
nos affranchis ce soir Fanny guinochet
qui va se pencher sur la voiture
électrique à 100 euros par mois promise
par Emmanuel Macron le regard de Vincent
Hugo sur le retour forcé des troupes
françaises au Niger et puis dans Bourbon
express de quoi nous parlez-vous à Elsa
mandagaba je vous parle du bureau de
l'Assemblée c'est la plus haute instance
à leur statu quo ou nouveau vote je
garde le suspense mais je vous réponds
en quelques minutes à tout de suite les
amis mais d'abord connaissez-vous la
génération
farniente parce qu'elle périt c'est
l'objet de votre livre aux éditions de
l'archipel une allergie
au travail qui gagnerait la jeunesse et
même au-delà et qui menacerait notre
modèle social à prendre très très au
sérieux selon vous voilà dans
l'invitation de Me Baptiste garguy
Chartier on en parle avec vous juste
après
si on vous invite Pascal Perry c'est
pour le coup de gueule que vous poussez
contre la paresse illustration dans
votre dernière ouvrage génération
farniente un essai polémique qui aborde
le désamour du travail de toute une
génération vous y apporter un point de
vue économique historique et social
qui choisit plutôt l'assistanat plutôt
l'assurance sociale telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui distribuée en France on va
leur dire vous devez désormais préféré
le travail ça ce serait une vraie
révolution
Pascal Perry vous êtes journaliste
écrivain et chef d'entreprise votre
ouvrage le plus marquant sans doute
celui sur le pouvoir d'achat mais dans
votre dernier essai vous proposez une
réforme du système économique
si on veut conserver le modèle qui est
le nôtre il faudra travailler plus en
quantité en qualité à retenir une idée
simple le travail c'est le seul capital
de ceux qui n'ont pas de capital il faut
donc le préserver
dans votre ligne de mire travailler plus
pour une société solidaire votre tête
s'appuie sur des statistiques vous
comparez la France à ses voisins comme
l'Italie l'Allemagne ou encore les pays
nordiques puis vous revenez sur des
faits marquants qui ont façonné notre
rapport au travail
d'abord mai 68
la crise sanitaire ou encore la réforme
des retraites
votre récipro ensuite une dimension plus
politique lorsque vous critiquez la
gauche actuelle sur ses positions
relatives au travail discours que vous
jugez irresponsable
moi
[Musique]
la gauche d'aujourd'hui milite dans
certains cas pour la disparition du
travail dites-vous Pascal Perry vous
dites que la France est confrontée à un
vaste mouvement d'allergie au travail
alors une question comment guérir cette
allergie
réponse une bonne question d'abord la
formation la question de la formation
qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure avec les
parlementaires il y a beaucoup de gens
qui sont hors du travail parce qu'ils
n'ont pas la bonne formation il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont de mauvais
revenu qui ont des revenus insuffisants
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de formation donc
je crois que tout commence à l'école
vous savez au fond l'emploi c'est
l'étage supérieur de l'étage éducation
dans votre lit vous parlez d'école du
travail mâché oui et je pense que le
goût de l'effort ne s'apprend plus tout
à fait il y a des responsabilités
partagées moi je rencontre des
professeurs qui sont parfois un peu
désespérés des parents qui se comportent
un peu comme des consommateurs c'est
quand j'étais jeune qu'en instituteur
[Musique]
mauvaise remarque sur le carnet de notes
mais mes parents m'en parlaient pour
promener c'est lui qui a raison
aujourd'hui quand ça se produit la même
façon vous avez des parents qui vont
voir le le professeur pour l'engueuler
ça c'est absolument inacceptable il faut
respecter le savoir respecter les
connaissances et puis c'est vrai qu'il y
a un fond général dans la société
peut-être que la société du 20e siècle a
été structurée autour du travail que
le temps de loisir le temps de famille
s'articulait d'abord autour du temps
professionnel il y a aujourd'hui une
génération de jeunes gens qui font
écouter d'ailleurs avec des compétences
des appétences complètement différentes
qui considèrent que le cocon familial la
vie personnelle sait le centre de la vie
et que au fond le travail est un élément
satellite le seul problème c'est
généralement un parce que c'est une
chose de ne pas vouloir travailler plus
longtemps et ça le rejet il était massif
dans la réforme des retraites aucune
réforme des retraites entre nous n'est
populaire mais c'est une autre de
considérer que on veut vite aller se
reposer on veut vite en finir et que le
travail rend malheureux est-ce que c'est
notre cas France vraiment moi je crois
pas que le travail rentre malheureux je
pense que d'abord un discours politique
mais je constate en même temps qu'il y a
ce que j'appelle une génération Netflix
déliveroo qui a élu le canapé comme le
centre du monde et qui est extrêmement
passive alors en quelques minutes c'est
compliqué d'en parler il y a l'école il
y a probablement l'éruption du digital
dans la vie qui fabrique plutôt des
individus passifs que des individus
actifs il y a un fond de l'air politique
on a entendu Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui nous
dire faut travailler moins travailler
tous mais pardon on a l'expérience des
35 heures le chômage a massivement
augmenté en France il suffit de
constater que les statistiques le disent
pour le croire le chômage a massivement
augmenté après la réforme des 35 heures
la réduction du temps de travail
donc absolument la réduction du temps de
travail n'a pas créé d'emploi en France
non je crois qu'il faut travailler sur
les qualifications et ne pas oublier un
principe fondamental qui est un peu le
cœur de ma réflexion la France a fait un
choix historique qui est de faire
financer son modèle social par le
travail par les actifs par les actifs et
donc c'est la quantité de travail dans
la société et la qualité du travail donc
la productivité qui finance le modèle
social qui est le nôtre moins d'actifs
si nous avions si nous avions le taux
d'emploi des Allemands ou celui des
Danois nous aurions en France et ça
réglera une partie des problèmes qui ont
été évoqués tout à l'heure 100 milliards
d'euros de recettes publiques
supplémentaires est-ce que vous vous
rendez compte de ce qu'on peut faire
avec 100 milliards d'euros donc si tout
le monde se met à travailler si la
quantité de travail est suffisante dans
la société une grande partie de nos
problèmes y compris budgétaires sont
réglés
presque au fond vous dites que c'est
culturel qu'on aurait presque perdu le
sens de l'intérêt collectif alors de
l'intérêt commun oui mais travailler
plus nous permettrait véritablement de
beaucoup mieux vivre il y a quelque
chose qui est fondamentalement invisible
et retrancher sur chose tout ça traduit
une société de d'égoïste bien sûr le
sens de la solidarité c'est un petit peu
perdu heureusement d'ailleurs qu'il y a
encore une vraie sécurité sociale des
institutions sociales en France parce
que c'est ce qui permet de verser les
retraites c'est ce qui permet de soigner
les gens dans de bonnes conditions de
politique de l'enfant mais ce que leur
portage tout à l'heure le petit résumé
était très bien parce que moi je pense
que le fait générateur c'est l'échec de
la réindustrialisation du pays c'est le
milieu des années 80 il y a deux écoles
aux partitionnistes et le Parti
socialiste qui gouverne c'est François
Mitterrand et président de la République
il y a les petite cresson qui dit mais
la désindustrialisation n'est pas une
fatalité il faut réinvestir moderniser
l'outil de travail mais on délocalise
les bras d'une en partie mais on
conserve de l'industrie en France et
puis il y a le l'autre école qui
l'emportera finalement qui est celle de
Martine Aubry qui dit après tout les
pertes industrielles c'est le produit de
la mondialisation on va on va on va
imaginer une économie de service du
temps libre etc ça nous a mené dans le
mur ça car les Allemands nos voisins ont
choisi d'investir massivement non pas
dans la retraite à 52 ans ce qu'on a
fait dans la sidérurgie dans le textile
mais dans la modernisation de l'outil de
travail c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles aujourd'hui l'Allemagne reste
un pays industriel c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles on s'est
désindustrialisé et on en a fini par
considérer qu'il était normal de ne plus
travailler à 52 ans comment voulez-vous
que dans une société les gens aient
envie de travailler quand on leur envoie
des signaux comme celui-là les 35 heures
alors vous êtes très dur d'ailleurs avec
la classe politique avec la gauche en
particulier vous parliez de du fond de
l'air tout à l'heure c'est vrai que les
slogans contre la réforme des retraites
ont pu interroger on a retrouvé
quelques-uns mais trop boulot tombeau
voilà la retraite on s'en fout on veut
pas bosser du tout boss consomme crève
droit à la paresse on envoie
quelques-uns pour vous la gauche
radicale aujourd'hui est la première
responsable on entend descendre une
Rousseau est-ce que vous ne lui donnez
pas un peu trop d'importance qu'elle est
en réalité dans l'opinion je pense
qu'elle a une à la qualifiée de
dangereuse je crois qu'elle a un impact
culturel fort c'est le
changement d'opinion enfin la production
de l'opinion ça répond souvent à des
logiques minoritaires il faut 5% de gens
très convaincus pour faire une
révolution les autres suivent en général
non je crois qu'on a une gauche
aujourd'hui qui sur la base d'un rapport
de Terra Nova d'ailleurs au début des
années 2010 disait la classe ouvrière
est perdue la classe ouvrit a été
pervertie par le capital si vous voulez
pour dire les choses simplement les
nouveaux révolutionnaires sont dans les
cités dans les banlieues c'est les
luttes intersectionnelles et vous avez
aujourd'hui une gauche qui dit
clairement mais comme Sandrine Rousseau
je ne l'ai pas inventé une bonne sieste
pour remplacer le capitalisme ou qui dit
oui ni loi ni travail au moment de la
loi el khomri ni loin ni traque donc ça
ça a un impact évidemment et comment
France on a une politique extrêmement
généreuse comme on sort d'une période
d'argent magique ça alimente cette idée
que au fond le non travail est possible
qu'on a totalement décorrélé le principe
du travail et le principe des revenus du
travail alors vous reprenez la formule
de Sylvain Tess qui dit que la France
est un paradis peuplé de gens qui se
croient en enfer cette idée que la
France est un enfer social vous avez
vraiment le sentiment qu'elle est
majoritaire dans le pays
tout à l'heure on veut faire la poche
des pauvres non c'est pas sérieux le
syndicat majoritaire
mais est-ce que c'est ce qu'on entend il
y a dans l'espace on vit dans une
société d'opinion c'est pas vous qui me
direz le contraire
l'opinion est déterminante c'est elle
qui produit une espèce de récit
collectif mais la voie de la majorité
n'est pas entendue elle est très peu
entendue on entend beaucoup des voies
respirates oui heureusement qu'elle
s'exprime dans les urnes mais là on ne
parle pas d'élection on est en train de
parler du fond idéologique dans la
société et en effet il y a une
sur-reprétation de de cette parole qui
remet en cause les grands équilibres qui
oublient de rappeler que le travail
produit la protection sociale qui
voudrait
désigner une partie du pays comme le
principal responsable des des malheurs
collectifs les riches de façon générale
en oubliant
écoutez et de faire en sorte qu'on
retrouve un peu ce goût de l'effort et
du travail pour le bien commun de tous
et donc pour nous écoutez on vit dans un
pays formidable on est assuré sur un
social de la naissance à la mort
c'est-à-dire l'État et les organismes
sociaux couvrent les aléas de la vie ça
il faut le protéger et la meilleure
façon de le protéger c'est de travailler
allez
tout c'est à dire aux éditions de
l'archipel vous restez avec moi Pascal
Perry c'est leur des partis pris de nos
affranchis pour terminer cette émission
ils vont vous faire réagiront les
accueille tout de suite
de France Info pour l'économie le
l'international avec le corps porter
Vincent Hugo bienvenue à vous ravi de
vous retrouver pour cette nouvelle
saison on commence vous le savez par
Bourbon Express comme chaque soir et
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
nationale nous est racontée ce soir par
Elsa Montana bonsoir Elsa bonsoir et
cette histoire je vais commencer par la
fin tout ça pour ça bon ça fait pas
vraiment envie mais je vous promets
c'est tout de même intéressant l'acteur
principal de cette histoire c'est le
bureau de l'Assemblée pas un vulgaire
bureau le bureau c'est la plus haute
instance ici c'est celle qui est chargée
de prendre toutes les décisions
importantes à les composer de 22 membres
regardez la présidente de l'Assemblée si
vice-président trois questeurs 12
secrétaires ce bureau il a été élu il y
a un an normalement il est reconduit
quasi automatiquement normalement sauf
que ça ne vous a pas échappé on n'est
pas tout à fait dans une assemblée
normale on s'attendait donc à quelques
péripéties et donc ce sont les
écologistes qui ont voulu remettre en
cause la composition de cet instant six
stratégique exactement à cause des vices
présidents pas de tous les vices
présidents des deux derniers Sébastien
Chenu Hélène Laporte devise président RN
pour les écologistes il fallait
provoquer un nouveau vote il n'accepte
pas que des postes clés puissent
appartenir aux parties de Marine Le Pen
c'est vrai que dans la majorité certains
avaient voté pour ses vices présidents
mais avait fait état de certains remords
avec qualifiés d'erreur ce soit ce choix
fait il y a un an alors pourtant ce sont
ces mêmes écologistes qui finalement
alors que cette réunion s'est tenue il y
a quelques heures on parle demandé de
renouvellement de ce bureau exactement
statu quo à l'unanimité des groupes que
l'on savait déjà c'est les groupes de la
majorité poussaient pour ce statu quo la
présidente de l'Assemblée s'était
exprimée en ce sens ce matin Elisabeth
borde qui était présente à la réunion
inter-groupe avait redit on ne peut pas
exclure les extrêmes de nos institutions
mais donc finalement les écologistes
n'ont pas demandé de nouveaux votes au
grand désarroi de leur présidente
qu'on a pu que prendre acte constater
que finalement les mêmes votes donner
les mêmes résultats et donc reconduire à
un vote ça serait finalement comment
c'est un vote dont on connaît déjà
l'issue donc on a pu que prendre acte de
ce refus de la part de la majorité de
revenir sur ce que nous on considère une
faute originelle c'est à dire d'avoir
porté leur voix sur des vices présidents
du rassemblement national alors la
vérité elle est un tout petit peu plus
compliquée déjà les écologistes ils
avaient organisé une consultation en
interne et la majorité des députés
étaient pour le statu quo non pas qu'il
se satisface de la présence de de
vice-présidents RN mais parce qu'ils se
sont bien rendu compte qu'ils y avait
trop de risques qu'ils avaient trop à
perdre la nupaisse avait trop à perdre
et puis ouvrir la boîte de Pandore sur
des nouveaux votes c'était risqué de se
retrouver encore moins bien servi voilà
pourquoi donc le 2 octobre ce même
bureau sera reconduit sans vote merci
beaucoup pour toutes ces informations
coulisses de la vie du Palais Bourbon
Bourbon Express c'est tous les soirs
vous le savez dans cette émission Fanny
on va revenir sur une promesse président
lequel la voiture a 100 euros la voiture
électrique bien sûr à 100 euros par mois
c'est le fameux leasing d'Emmanuel
Macron comment ça va marcher exactement
alors sur le papier c'est assez simple
c'est ce que dit Emmanuel Macron l'idée
c'est donc d'avoir une voiture
électrique moins polluante pour 100
euros par mois ça n'est pas une prime
mais vous pouvez vous pourrez bénéficier
de cette voiture électrique sans avoir
un apport à mettre au départ et
normalement et bien c'est une promesse
présidentielle qui date déjà de quelques
mois mais qui devrait voir le jour
prochainement en tout cas c'est ce qu'a
dit Emmanuel Macron parce qu'on en sait
un petit peu plus sur l'agenda on va
pouvoir faire les premières réservations
des lois de novembre pour des premières
livraisons en début d'année attention
cette voiture électrique elle ne
s'adressera qu'au ménage les moins
fortunés les plus modestes l'idée c'est
de les aider de les accompagner dans la
transition écologique
connaissez pas en revanche quels
critères sur quels critères qui sera
riche considérés par riche etc
on ne sait pas non plus encore quel
véhicule entreront dans le dispositif si
c'est une mini berline une voiture
familiale pour l'instant c'est le flou
alors en attendant de connaître les
modèles et les niveaux de revenus
concernés on sait en revanche que ce
seront des voitures made in France ou
fabriquées en Europe voilà la volonté de
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est de ne pas
subventionner en fait des voitures
chinoises asiatiques parce que quand
vous faites un leasing à 100 euros en
fait ça coûte beaucoup plus cher et la
différence c'est l'État qui va la
prendre en charge et donc c'est une
forme de subvention pas question donc de
subventionner des voitures chinoises ce
sont surtout celles-ci qui sont visées
parce qu'on sait que les chinois sont
extrêmement offensifs finalement sur la
voiture électrique alors en même temps
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour le climat
et l'idée sur le papier elle est
séduisante on se dit effectivement ça va
être c'est une bonne idée sauf que sauf
que il faut voir la réalisation et pour
l'instant ça reste très très flou il
faut voir comment cette mesure va va se
concrétiser surtout que bon évidemment
il y a l'achat de la voiture la location
de la peinture en fait mais il faudra
aussi payer l'électricité bref ça fait
beaucoup d'inconnus est-ce que les
ménages concernés est-ce qu'il y en a
beaucoup déjà vont se convertir à la
voiture électrique en location c'est pas
sûr donc autant vous dire que cette
promesse risque d'être déceptive vous y
croyez d'un mot parce qu'elle périt je
suis pas convaincu par la voiture
électrique d'une part je sais que ça en
général de façon générale c'est un bilan
je voudrais un bilan complet un bilan
jusqu'à la disparition le recyclage mais
les la voiture électrique c'est les cinq
premiers des cils du revenu donc c'est
des gens dont le revenu est inférieur à
22000 euros par an un peu de choses près
la question que pose fanny est la bonne
c'est-à-dire quelle voiture sera
éligible puisqu'on sait que qui est une
voiture française et fabriquée en Chine
donc exclu que la petite mg ancienne
marque anglaise reprise par les Chinois
qui était éligibles à la prime à 100
euros est exclue parce que fabriqué en
Chine quelle voiture à mettre entre les
mains de ses conducteurs on va attendre
encore quelques jours pour avoir ces
réponses attendues on termine avec vous
Vincent et je sais au détour d'une
intervention à la télévision qu'Emmanuel
Macron a donc annoncé le retour imminent
de notre ambassadeur à Niamey et puis
celui à la fin de l'année des 1500
militaires français déployés au Niger
ainsi s'achève piteusement un bras de
fer voué à l'échec alors certes Paris
invoquait un bon droit les préceptes du
droit international soutient au
président élu mohamed Bazoum allié loyal
des logets fin juillet prend un
quarteron de gallonné insatiable ou amer
refus de traiter avec une jinte par
essence illégitime
postulat aussi noble que 20 pour peu
qu'on les mesure à l'aune du principe de
réalité l'ambassadeur de France à Niamey
martenait l'Élysée a été pris en otage
par les poutchistes Nigériens mais ce
chef de mission chevronnée Sylvain it
fut autant l'otage de l'entêtement
d'Emmanuel Macron que celui des
puccistes tous mes interlocuteurs
diplomates africains vieux routier du
Quai d'Orsay militaire vétérandus
renseignement mon confessé la perplexité
que leur inspirait l'obstination
présidentielle notamment parce qu'elle
perpétuait in situ un abcès de fixation
de nature à intensifier le ressentiment
anti-français parce qu'elle promettait à
la propagande souverainiste des padernes
sahéliennes un triomphe romain à ville
prix tout ça pour ça bis alors pourquoi
cette obstination comme vous dites
inutile outre lubrisse élyséen deux
facteurs éclairent cet impasse d'abord
la France misait à tort sur une
intervention militaire de la CEDEAO
l'instance ouest africaine censé
rétablir Bazoum sur son trône
républicain ensuite elle a sous-estimé
son propre isolement aggravé par la
posture équivoque des états enclin à
l'évidence à transiger avec la jointe au
Sahel l'ancienne puissance coloniale
rêvait d'une réduction de voilure
graduelle et ordonnée de son dispositif
militaire baisse des effectifs emprunte
au sol à moindrie visibilité réduite
l'échec du combat engagé contre le
djihadisme et la cascade de coup d'état
survenu au Mali au Burkina Faso puis au
Niger ont enrayé cette mécanique du
désengagement voulu on est passé à des
bacs subis c'est la fin de tout ce
dispositif que va-t-il devenir bien en
1960 à l'orée des indépendants recensé
30 000 soldats français sur le continent
noir dans l'espace saélien ils étaient
environ 5000 à l'apogée de l'opération
par Cannes combien à la fin de cette
année au terme du retrait des 1500
déployés au Niger un peu plus de 4000
dispersés sur 5 points d'ancrage d'ouest
en est le Sénégal la Côte d'Ivoire le
Gabon un millier au Tchad et 1500 à
Djibouti balcon sur la mer Rouge autant
de contingents appelés à décliner au fil
des ans à quel rythme mystère une
certitude dans un contexte propice à la
liquidation des arrières écoloniaux
l'hypothèse d'une fermeture définitive
des bases permanentes n'a plus rien
d'incongru fini les ingérences sur la
terre de nos ancêtres clairon les
puchistes Nigériens souhaitent ce qu'ils
omettent de préciser c'est que la terre
sacrée des aïeux est aussi gorgée du
sang des villageois massacrés par les
portefles du Jihad tous les rapports
latex au Mali au face au Niger les
puccistes ne font pas mieux loin s'en
fout que leur prédécesseurs civils ni
sur le front sécurité ni en terme de
gouvernance tôt ou tard l'illusion
lyrique quasi messianique qu'incarne
l'officier réputé intègre et patriotes
se dissipera piètre consolation vute
Paris car l’épilogue n'avran des
mésaventures de l'ambassadeur Sylvain
été confirme le caractère inexorable du
déclin de l'influence de la France en
Afrique en la matière la masse édite it
Misa est
bravo pour cette chute toujours aussi
acérée la plume de Vincent eugieux c'est
c'est le fiasco total pour la France une
claque en Afrique ou c'est plus
compliqué que ça c'est la fin d'une
époque il y a des choses qui sont un
petit peu plus compliquées Vincent a dit
vous l'expliqué mais dans les rapports
de force entre les militaires militaire
et le président Bazoom il y a une
dimension un petit peu ethnique aussi on
raconte par exemple que lors de la
première rencontre entre le chef de la
junte et le président Bazoum le chef de
la jungle aurait traité Bazoum de sale
arabe ça dit beaucoup de choses sur les
relations entre les uns les rapports de
force il y a pas qu'un rapport de force
politique il y a d'autres choses dans le
pays merci
votre éclairage d'avoir été notre grand
témoin Pascal Perri génération farniente
aux éditions de l'archipel pourquoi tant
de Français ont perdu le goût du travail
et que vous soyez d'accord ou pas ça
donne envie de débattre merci à vous les
accrochures à très vite à demain sans
doute elles amont d'un gars va très
belle soirée sur LCP pour voir ou revoir
cette émission la chaîne Youtube de LCP
bien sûr à demain
[Musique]